now I address directly to president of
the United States Biden here from the
small Israel to the big United States of
America
don't just imagine the people back in
the day when they would have to travel
certain distances for months or even
years what is one thing that they would
carry with them the Quran why because
they did not have it on their mobile
devices or their gadgets brothers and
sisters imagine you have a app the Quan
app which not only shows you how much
rewards you get but reminds you to read
the Quran gives you reminders download
the Quran app now and let it testify for
you on that you read it wherever you
was brothers and sisters and dear
friends listen very carefully and just
imagine and close your eyes and just
think if this was a Muslim woman in
hijab on a TV interview in a Muslim
country
saying that we should get rid of the
Zionist or the Jews for that matter and
we should why should we destroy their
houses and blow them up why so we can
have a nice view of the sea listen to it
you cannot make this up this is coming
from the Zionist your lay
individuals these you cannot make this
up from the lay individuals to the MPS
to the prime minister to the defend
minister to your IDF soldiers to your
Tom Dick and Harry Zan supporter working
in your or whatever this is the ideology
that they have this out of this you got
you got listen to this guy this is this
is
crazy
yet I think that now I address directly
to president of the United States Biden
here from the small Israel to the big
United States of America
don't think that we will stop the war in
Gaza before be put a total end to Hamas
to the supporters of Hamas
and resettling the entire area of Gaza
by Jews okay Daniela the message to this
despicable woman the only thing you're
going to see with
certainty like Allah says says in the
Quran that there will be that day your
eyesight is going to be sharp 2020
Vision when the soul the angel is taking
your soul and he says come out to the
wrath of your lord and Allah says if
only you saw when the Angels were taking
their sword how they were smiting their
backs brothers and sisters these people
are oppresses zionists these zionists
have no damn Mercy on any
anybody no children no like imagine this
when Isis came about yes you know from
public speakers like myself to your lame
Muslim man who works in the shop to
anybody from the the imams to the Muslim
leaders every single person was
condemning them why cuz it's not a part
of our religion how is it crazy that
these individuals from all different
lives sist are all unanimous ly saying
and promoting the absolute genocide of
the Palestinians you cannot make this up
you cannot make this stuff up they are
screaming for their voices screaming out
loud it shows nothing but self amazement
arrogance and they have some kind of
assurance Allah subhana wa ta'ala hits
from you will never expect Allah subhana
T will come from an angle you would
never expect so carry on the Arab an
carry on the genocide carry on your
apoide
state Allah is not going to God Almighty
is not going to let an injustice like
that carry on there will be an end to
the oppression that you guys do and I
hope that we will live to see that the
Palestinians return back to their lands
as
Palestine and that the Muslims the Jews
and the Christians who lived there for
centuries come back to living together
again and get the hell
rid of these that's all I'm going to say
brother and
sisters